i got to be very honest with you and i
know this isn't
popular enough with the donating to the
kids in the hospital with cancer
no one believes that the money's going
to them and it's the same kid over and
over again
you're not fooling me it's the same bald
kid over and over again
i can you tell them apart it's to say
why am i going to the fat store and
don't
everyone in the fat store is dying why
are there more
dead people when i check out can it can
you explain to me
why i gotta look at this cancerous child
who looks
pretty [ __ ] skinny by the way all the
fat
people when they check out of the fat
store have to look at these emaciated
children we're
jealous as [ __ ] we're not donating money
we want to know how they look like that
how do they see their rib cage
and i gotta look at emaciated cancer
kids to make me feel like [ __ ]
and then you gotta ask me for a dollar
to help these skinny [ __ ]
i think not let me out of the fat store
and just let me go and the other thing
dxl
you pieces of [ __ ] stop
giving the paper 25
reward get rid of the rewards at the fat
store
number one get rid of them
we shouldn't even have the fat rewards
at dxl you shouldn't say
hey you're fat again this month here's
25 come back here next month if you
don't have a coronary
and and get 25 off 190
shirt because apparently it's four times
the price
of anything else cause you're fat so
they give you this
25 little piece of
thing and you lose it they don't give
you any digital rewards
you lose and they go bring it back next
month they give you and i yell at them
now i go this is